hi i'm michael fitzgerald i'm a
contributing editor at mit sloan
management review welcome to our latest
look at how large traditional companies
are engaging in digital transformation
today i'm talking with executives from
houghton mifflin harcourt the 1.3
billion publisher of trade books and
k-12 educational content to my right are
linda zecker the ceo and president of
houghton mifflin harcourt and to her
right is mary cullinan the company's new
chief content officer
houghton mifflin harcourt is a famous
name in trade publishing but we're here
today to talk about its dominant
business which we know as textbooks the
6.3 billion market for k-12 textbooks is
undergoing dramatic change although not
at the same rate as the market for
university textbooks
k-12 school districts run a vast gamut
in size and income levels of the
families whose children attend them or
the communities that fund them and in
access to technology they also face
significant constraints what they teach
must map to state and national standards
so transformation in this industry is
not something that a company can just
dictate on its own
i say these things as context for this
discussion linda mary thank you for
being with us today thank you for having
us linda i want to start with you you
joined hotel harcourt from
a technology company microsoft in
september 2011 about a year and a half
ago when you came in
what were you thinking you were going to
need to do
in this in this industry what i didn't
realize until i became ceo of hope
mifflin was that um
we were really in this transformation of
trying to leverage technology but we
didn't really we were the industry is
moving at a very different pace
depending upon the school district et
cetera so i had to really kind of step
back and think about it's just not about
technology it's about the blending of
technology and great content and this is
not something where you just go in and
throw technology at a problem you have
to think about it as a holistic solution
when you joined hogan mifflin harcourt
it was a company that had sort of a
legacy of some bad management decisions
behind it uh a lot of debt had been
piled up you also had to deal with uh
sort of operational transformation which
did you
have to address first well i sort of
dealt with them all at the same time i
mean there's sort of three you know legs
to the stool and getting our balance
sheet cleaned up and getting our fiscal
house in order so that we could you know
you know put money into the areas that
we really wanted to develop that was a
key component of this the second thing
was really bringing in a t you know a
top tier management team that could
really help us manage the business and
make sure that we have the right people
in place so that once we did clean up
the company we had the people that could
take the leadership role and move the
company forward and the third component
was really making sure that we had great
content we have a wonderful brand and
we're well known in the school districts
and we have incredible market share so
being able to then take that and
leverage it and take it to the next tier
and how we were going to transform
education through that rich content with
technology
we're in an industry well we're in a
culture really where there's a kind of
techno-determinism we believe that
we believe that technology can fix all
problems uh
what's the reality for the education
market depending on where you're at in
the country but it's kind of interesting
i mean obviously we have a lot of
investors that invest in the company and
many of them are in new york and on the
east coast and so their children are
going to very high-end education schools
and and so there tends to be this
mentality in these very high-end schools
that if you throw an ipad at a child
they're going to learn russian and
that's just not the case i mean there's
a lot more to the process of learning
and when you think about it from grades
like kindergarten or even preschool
through like fourth grade you're really
learning how to learn you're learning
the fundamentals you're learning how to
read you're learning how to write you're
learning how to spell you're learning
all the fundamentals and basic math from
beyond that you're really becoming
educated and so when you get outside of
some of these really high-end schools
that can afford the very top technology
and the great support systems that are
there you realize that the rest of the
country doesn't even have the technology
infrastructure in the schools to even
manage technology and then you don't
have teachers and content that is really
geared around technology so when you
look at the technologies that you can
bring to bear to try to help with
learning uh
in in a formal school environment
what are the ones that you feel are
have the most potential to to in fact
change education part of the challenge
is many people
think about the problem that way and
what we would like to see more of is
people thinking about here's the process
that we go through in teaching and
learning here's recognition of prior
knowledge
here's collaboration here's
reinforcement here's assessment and then
when you look at those steps in the
learning process
where does technology play and what type
of
technology can play a piece in making
that element of the process more
efficient more effective um
allow all kids to have a more
personalized experience what we see in
classrooms a lot are that they start
with the technology they get the
whiteboard and then they put it in the
classroom and they say okay now what are
we going to do with it they get the
laptop and they put it in the classroom
they get the ipad they put it into the
classroom and then they try they try to
reverse engineer and what we're trying
to do is take a step back and look at
the elements of the learning process and
then figure out what technology whatever
it may be whatever it needs to be will
enhance or or increase the effectiveness
of that component so how are you doing
that well you know if you look at things
like game theory
that that's a great opportunity for us
and again we it starts it starts to get
a little noisy in the marketplace
because folks feel like it's all about
gamification and you hear that word all
the time the real the real excitement
around gamification should be game
theory
when you play angry birds which i'm
assuming you've
dabbled in a little bit guilty
you know the first two levels you will
do well in and there's a theory behind
that because they want you to have a
positive experience in that challenge
and when you have a positive experience
and a challenge you're more likely to
come back
we know that kids today when they're
playing games are failing about 80
percent of the time in that experience
these are educational games games in
general and what do they keep doing
coming back
because they've created an environment
where they they recognize if i keep
doing this i'm going to have an
opportunity for success and yet we
haven't created that environment in our
classrooms so when we think about the
power of gaming we should think about
the game theory that's behind it and how
do we take those lessons and apply it to
the teaching and learning process as
opposed to let's just
gamify everything and throw in front of
our kids so can you give an example of
how you are managing that process and
trying to bring more effective use of
gaming techniques into the education
process well one of the things that we
did we just acquired a company called
tribalnova they've already been doing a
lot with pbs kids and they've created
a lot of different games using
characters around the whole idea of
pre-k learning and gamification
and so we've been working with them and
then we acquired them and one of the
things that we're looking at is taking
many of our iconic brands that we have
on the trade side of the house like
curious george
and gertie little blue truck things like
that and really trying to figure out is
there a way that we can take them
and meld them in with the learning
experience around math or reading to
make this more fun but make it something
that the kids can engage in by
themselves and or with their parents or
teachers but in a way that makes it fun
for them so they want to continue to go
to the next level we've done we have 34
apps today that we have out on the ipad
or the iphone not all the same
experience some are better than others
but as we move forward we're trying to
do more and more of this and we're
experimenting with those types of things
another thing that we're doing
is that we have a math pro program
called go math and so we've taken the go
math program
we went out and we got some puppeteers
very similar to the sesame street types
of puppets and we're actually using
those in creating lessons so it would be
a lesson on maybe a geometry theory or
it might be a lesson on just a basic
math theory or something else but it's
with a professor and with a puppet and
making it a fun kind of learning thing
so the children can go back and not just
learn in the classroom and then maybe go
back and review that in a fun kind of
environment just like kukla fran and
ollie meet khan academy exactly exactly
exactly but all of that tied to common
core and tied to the pedagogy of the
curriculum that's necessary for the
learning experience and that's a big
difference between us and just someone
coming out with the game because if you
just come out with a game it's not tied
to anything else that the kids are
learning if you tie it in with what
they're doing in the classroom what they
need to do around common core at what
needs to be done at various different
stages of learning and then you have a
better chance of really having that
individualized experience that mary was
talking about and so when when this
plays out i mean you're not
there are obviously programs that i can
download uh or go to the web or have my
kids download and go to the web on
you're talking about integrating this in
with a classroom experience correct so
how does that work take one of these 34
apps and show us how that would play out
in us in a classroom you know you start
to see the way that instruction is being
delivered to change a little bit in
which
when we probably all were in classrooms
there was a teacher in front of the
class and folks were in rows and we all
turned the page at the same time
and now what we're starting to see more
of is teachers trying to figure out
given the great differential of aptitude
within their classrooms how do they
address the individual needs of those
kids so in some you know you start to
see more pods being created you start to
see more individualized instruction you
start to see you know greater elasticity
to the type of pedagogy that teachers
are using in their classrooms so you'll
have some kids over here where the
appropriate tool for them with their
need right then and there is is a game
it could have three ipads in the
classroom and those three kids are on
something over here you'll have kids who
are being remediated with a teacher
instruction so a teacher sitting with
them and going over over there in the
back you might have three kids who are
doing great working on their own right
now and so what we're trying to do is
bring that ability to adapt our
instruction adapt content adapt the way
it's being distributed
for what's best for that kid and the
thing i worry about is you know
sometimes in the industry we think that
every problem can be solved by one
solution and i guarantee you when you're
in a classroom and you have 36 kids in
front of you every single one of them is
going to learn differently and there's
not going to be one trick that you're
going to be able to pull out of your bag
that's going to address all those needs
and we have to remember that in the
solutions and the resources and the
tools that we bring to bear or else
we're going to leave kids behind you
know another point on that is in the
early 70s there was this entire push
towards open classrooms and everyone was
going to an open classroom the problem
with the open classroom one of the
reasons that it failed in so many cases
was that they just thought they're going
to have an open classroom and they'd
give all these kids their own book and
everyone could go off and learn on their
own there was going to be all this
individualized learning what they didn't
put behind that was the individualized
instruction materials they didn't put
behind that the teacher development or
professional development that was needed
in order to know how to manage a
classroom like that and they didn't have
any of the tools that were necessary for
the various different degrees that that
children were at some are very quick
some are not some need you know
remediation some need you know other
things and so they didn't really have
any of that stuff around it so it's
almost like we've gone full circle to
where we know the individualized
instruction is a great way for kids to
learn and it works but it doesn't work
if you don't have the proper tools and
and the proper teacher support to be
able to make it work effectively are you
foreseeing an educational environment
where the assumption is that the kid is
going to have a device of some sort that
is in the classroom that they are going
to use to
to
to be educated to complement what the
teacher is doing as opposed to you know
having the teacher take the device away
when they walk in the door which is what
happens i think it's a given they're
going to have a device i think that's a
given and i don't think that if you're
in this marketplace and you think that's
not the direction that the industry is
going i think you have your head in the
sand so that's definitely a given and i
think that a lot of it's going to be
mobile and as you go outside the u.s
mobile is probably a little faster than
you're seeing in the us it's just trying
to you know back to what mary said
trying to make sure that you optimize
for that particular device to make sure
that you've got it set in a way that
they can really get the richest
experiences that they can where we have
seen the space lag a little bit is the
types of devices that they're bringing
in and using or the devices that are
being provided to them so outside in the
consumer space you probably see more
hits to a website right now coming from
a smartphone where if you look at our
website more hits are coming to our
website off of a laptop so
the reality though is that right now for
instance if my seventh grader and my
fifth grader bring their cell phone to
school
they don't come out in the classroom the
teachers don't want them there students
in general are going to be more
interested in something other than
the curriculum i mean they're going to
pull those things out and look at them
when they're bored right so are you
working with school districts on how to
manage the the boredom factor the the
multi-purpose nature of the devices
we're discussing well that's where one
of the biggest challenges is and that's
why we sometimes push back that
technology is going to solve all the
problems because you know you if you're
thinking about a first grade class or a
second grade class can you imagine 30
kids in the classroom all trying to have
a device in front of them and trying to
manage what they're doing one breaks
down this one doesn't work this one
can't find the page
all those kinds of things and so you're
going to spend all your teaching time
trying to solve a problem rather than
really you know instructing and so this
is the challenge that teachers are
facing and so there's a lot of
professional development and things like
that around how they can better manage
that but we're not there yet i mean it's
it's definitely a challenge and at the
same time you know even without
technology you will always have the case
in a classroom where kids are bored you
have one kid that's learning at one
level and another kid that's learning in
another and one's you know playing with
their pencils and the other ones you
know trying to read the book and that's
really where you can leverage technology
around this individualized instruction
so that as one kid gets bored you can
maybe challenge them with something
that's a little bit more difficult or
bring in a game or something like that
that they could potentially use to get
more engaged whereas the other child has
a different experience with a different
kind of individualized instruction the
teacher has a little
dashboard an effect on on his or her
desk or monitor where he can he or she
can sort of see what's going on with his
students and check in is that where
we're headed in some school systems
today you have kids who want to
one-to-one and they all have a device
and that teacher has literally has that
dashboard that you're referencing and
there's technology out there that they
can actually shut down an application
that's on the device that they see you
know that's out there we have school
systems in which kids are bringing their
phones into the schools and they're
taking them out to answer quiz so a
teacher will put a question up on a
screen and there's a software program
that they can actually text the answer
to and you'll see a graph come up to say
how many chose a how many chose b how
many shows c so all that stuff's in
there but at the end of the day it goes
back to the instruction and it goes back
to whether or not the pedagogy is there
the instructional quality is there and
these things sometimes i think just
become a little bit of a distraction in
the debate
teachers have always throughout their
careers throughout history have looked
for ways in which they can engage their
students
and now they're looking for different
tools to help make that happen
i don't think that story's changed at
all
so and i don't want to go too far afield
it's not like you make devices at hope
mifflin harcourt and you produce content
how
does technology affect the way that you
create and deliver content in a business
that is still predominantly a print
based business yes you know the way that
we're thinking about content is to your
point there has to be that flexibility
so that's kind of a design pillar for us
we have to ensure that the quality that
the pedagogy can be represented
represented in a textbook as well as on
a device so there's that requirement in
our design process
again we also want to take advantage of
the technology so how do we start to
develop kind of at the platform layer
these features and functionality that
take advantage of the fact that the kid
does have a device that they have access
to storage on the cloud that they have
the ability to
interact with their teacher that they
have the ability to dive deeper into a
piece of content that they see when they
double click on it so we have to think
differently about ensuring that we're
we're providing that content in a rich
way if it has to be delivered in print
but that we're taking advantage and
adding some tools and features and
functionality and then the third piece
that is incredibly exciting and i think
we're starting to see more through
partnerships is how do we start to
really deliver on what everybody's
talking about with adaptive learning so
in a digital context when i get a sense
of where the kid's going how can i
change that kid's instructional
direction based upon their acumen if
they do really well i want to give them
something harder if they don't do so
well i want to be able to remediate them
and a technical environment gathers that
data and is then able to point them into
a learning direction
by by recognizing certain content that's
tagged a certain way and then exposing
that to the learner so that's developing
a very different environment than what
the print would allow for so talk to us
about adaptive learning and and uh what
the what's enabling it uh what the
obstacles are to it in the market well i
think the the first thing about adaptive
learning is that you've got to have a
platform that can allow you to have all
of this different content drawn from
various different places and presented
in different ways so the tagging
elements and all the background work
that has to be done to make that
available is a key component once you
have all of that done the best part
about adaptive learning is that you you
really do have then the ability to serve
up you know whatever type of content is
necessary based on what that child is in
the learning experience and so if you
have a teacher and that is really
working across various different levels
of children she then has the ability or
he has the ability to pull that content
in so an adaptive learning is no more
than if you have a child that's you know
a a you know top student you give them
extracurricular activities or you give
them additional things to read or you
send them home with new books if you
have a child that's having problems you
put them in a tutorial and you give them
you know maybe a tutoring class or
additional homework or things like that
it's the same type of thing but it's
being served up very individualized and
it's being served up immediately so that
you can keep that child engaged and keep
them moving along on their continuum
we're really seeing it in its infancy
right now i mean adaptive learning will
get to a point where we can adapt on
multiple levels or multiple pivots we
should be able to adapt based upon your
preferences if you're really into golf
and you have to read a story why not
serve up a golf story
if you're really into skateboards and
you have to read a paragraph why not
serve up quickly a skateboard story so
that you're going to be able to take
advantage of that child's interest and
now they're going to be more engaged
we have to be able to adapt on acumen if
you're a fast reader if you're a slow
reader be able to pivot on that and then
we also have to be able to adapt on
learning style maybe you would be better
off in an online environment or you
would be better off in a manipulative
environment or you'd be better off
hearing something or you'd be better off
reading something so there's all these
different pivots that we need to get to
and we're not there how are you
structuring your organization to be able
to move towards this adaptive learning
environment well before we did
everything from a print perspective and
then we had a digital component and now
we're doing everything from a digital
component and print becomes a
distribution vehicle so in the old days
if a school wanted to adapt uh their
textbook maybe in their math continuum
they wanted to teach algebra one
geometry algebra two another school
might want to teach some algebra two
concepts with algebra one whatever you
would have to then go back you'd realign
the chapters you go back you print you
create a new book you do all these
additional things
now we can say okay you'd like to have
here's a through z you want a b and d
this time or you want a b and f this
time no problem it's a very you take a
content management system you pull the
components out and you just redistribute
them in a new way and you can do that on
the fly based on the needs of that
classroom or that student etc so so when
we think about how we're developing
we're developing everything in the idea
of having a learning object or
everything as a widget so that you can
pull it in in various different ways
very quickly to make this collective
content
and that flows in a pedagogically sound
way i know you're using analytics to try
to
do a better job of creating adaptive
curricular content
where are you in the process of this
adaptive learning curriculum and where
do you need to get to you know i think
right now the industry is very much at
its at its infancy i think we're
partnering right now with some great
folks who have built some solid analytic
engines and data cubes around that
process and we're starting to take
advantage of things like the cloud and
big data and all that that stuff that
folks are talking about
you have a couple of challenges
one for those environments to truly work
you need to have pervasive devices
throughout school systems
to really get the benefit of that of
that opportunity we're not quite there
yet two the the amount of data that or
data points that you're able to pull
that allow you to point the kid in the
next direction the end needs to be a
little bit bigger there
you know we just don't have the the
number of examples or the number of data
points that will get us to where we can
truly start to see some strong things
that the correlations are high enough
that we can build off of but we're
getting there and then three when you
really have a truly adaptive environment
you need a ton of tag content because
now instead of everybody just turning
the page to the other page that you know
is going to be there you need a ton of
content that regardless of where that
kid needs to go you have something
that's of quality and is tagged and
ready to be there and so we're
continuing to push that out this is
going to be a journey it's going to take
folks a little bit of time but i think
recognition of it is half the problem i
think we have the systems in place and i
think we have the right people thinking
about it so
how are you
as a company trying to address the the
personalization aspect of it well it
goes back to that infrastructure to that
platform that we're building out so it
goes back to the when we produce our
content now we tag it at a much more
granular level so we give it attributes
that recognize the content unit as
opposed to the book or program so we're
able to start pulling off of that
and then we're building that analytic
structure on top of it a place for when
a kid clicks here or answers this
question this way we gather that data
and are able to learn from it that takes
investment and that takes a little bit
of time a great example of that is some
of the things that are happening in
online tutorials with kids and and
having them you know in their homework
assignments and things like that is a
teacher being able to understand when
she looks at her dashboard or she looks
at the analytics that come out of the
assignments how long did it take them to
solve the problem how many times did
they click on help how many times did
they go back you know how quickly did
they get the first you know the right
answer and so those kinds of things are
helpful to the teacher to then go back
and be able to say okay maybe we need to
change how your homework is structured
or maybe we need to change how you're
getting this lesson presented in class
and so that's different than just online
or or you know individualized
instruction that really is adapting the
courseware and adapting your environment
to help you move forward
how has your hiring changed to produce
this well mary's an example of that i'm
an example of that i mean the entire
management team is is pretty much except
for a few exceptions pretty much out of
the technology environment and we've
brought a lot of new people into uh the
environment and the development group
they have uh gamification knowledge they
have
technology knowledge
different design knowledge and then
we've also brought a lot of people
across the board on the sales side that
know how to talk about technology and
know how to really present this to the
classroom so they can understand what
this is because remember you're selling
to teachers and you're selling to
superintendents many of which their only
experience with technology is what they
do on their own laptop at home they
don't really have a technology
background and so the idea of going in
front of 30 kids in a classroom and
having to meet all these standards that
the government's been putting in place
and being measured on that and then
having to do it in an environment that
you are completely uncomfortable is
really hard so there's a you know a lot
of process here i know that you've
shifted the organizational structure so
that you you've now got subject matter
experts who work with print and digital
instructional designers uh you know how
is this working and are you able to find
the skills you need for these these
designers yeah you know we're really
starting to change the way that we think
about the org and even
little things like look the titles that
they're starting to have you know
learning architects that's a different
title than an editor
and it seems is it the same job it's a
different job with the same hoping
hopefully with the same outcome the
production of quality content
and and but we have to think about it
differently with regards to
what what tools do i have to consider
when i'm producing that content before
you had a page
you know and you had to get so many
words on that page and you know you knew
how many graphs you were going to put on
that page and you know how many
paragraphs you were going to put on that
page now you you're not there are no
page numbers
there are no page numbers on this other
side and when you start to have that
type of freedom you have to think
differently about design you have to
think differently about the user
experience and what we're really trying
to focus on at hmh is having a
consistent hmh experience as opposed to
an experience in math and experience in
english and experience in reading
we want to we want to create that
continuum we want to create that brand
across all disciplines that takes
advantage of technology that takes
advantage of feature that takes
advantage of platform and not just focus
on one specific discipline in our
innovation do you feel like you've got a
pretty good handle on managing the
technology to help enable the change you
want or is the technology still
something you're trying to get your arms
around well i think we're in transition
i mean like everybody else we're in
transition and you know as a team we've
only been there about 18 months and so
there's a lot we have to do and i don't
think we have all the answers by any
stretch and we're obviously you know
technology is changing and how you use
it in the classroom and so we're trying
to stay ahead of the curve but we're
definitely not there i mean we're in
this journey also and so i think that we
have the some good ideas and i think we
have a good process in place and i think
we're on a very good journey of really
contributing to where we think we should
be from a technology standpoint but
we're not there yet and we have a lot
that we can probably learn and add to
and you know the adoption cycles in this
environment are much different they're
much faster right so the
the length of time that it took facebook
to get to 150 million users compared to
the length of time it took color
televisions to
populate our environment at 150 million
was drastically different and so now we
have this we have this reality where we
have different technologies that are
being adapted so much into the norm of
our experience and the education system
just can't react that quickly and so
there's always going to be that natural
tension there that i think we have to
recognize and respect and ensure that we
don't we don't move too fast but we take
advantage of of what the kids are using
and what the norms are
recognizing that that space isn't going
to move as fast as some others how much
leeway do you have in a country where we
teach to the test it's a challenge you
know it's very challenging and i think
you start to see
a mindset and an appropriate one you
know as a teacher i used to i used to
see that test and that yardstick as kind
of secondary i knew that if i created a
great learning environment and the kids
had a great experience and i addressed
the content the test was going to play
out they were going to they were going
to do okay there
and so the teach to the test mentality
yes you do have some in the classroom
who want to know exactly what they're
going to be tested on and they address
their instruction based upon that but
then there is the opportunity at the
macro level to say if i provide a great
learning environment great content the
kids will do well on the test and i
think coming from a technology
environment we really respect and
understand technology and we actually
love it it's great we always have the
newest devices and we're always playing
with the newest things
but we also understand that even in the
environment we came from that when we
were talking to our customers it was
about leveraging the technology to solve
a problem and a solution it wasn't about
the technology itself so
when you
are engaging with school districts or
even with individual teachers
they
have developed techniques for education
educating kids
this sounds like you're talking about
something that's
relatively dramatic change for them
how do you help them adapt how much
pushback do you get this is not going to
be an on off switch i mean this is a
dimmer and i say that all the time
because you know not all schools not all
teachers are going to be prepared to
make these kinds of transitions where
the industry is going at the same time
they're all very interested in trying
new things and trying to figure out how
they can enhance the learning experience
how influential or or uh
well how nervous does something like
khan academy make
a content publisher well i think khan
academy has they have their place and i
think they're they're great and i think
that if they can be utilized in the
learning experience great the difference
between khan academy and us is that we
can take the same content that we're
using in the classroom and we can
provide it online with online
instruction like the math and focus
videos i was talking about so we can do
the same thing and we're also moving
into online courseware and and and other
things like that so what we try to do is
make sure that we can interoperate and
try to make sure that whatever we're
providing that if you want to add
enrichment to that that we make that
available and we develop our content in
a way that you can add that in yeah i
mean the problem the challenges that
we're facing in this country with
regards to education the quality of it
are pretty big
and we as a country should want to bring
out every trick every tool every
resource that we can to improve upon
that and if khan academy is a solution
for some educators in their classrooms
great great but we recognize that at the
end of the day what we are able to
provide the type of quality the type of
pedagogy is something that teachers
trust something that superintendents
trust something that parents trust and
we're proud of that and so so one of the
the big issues in american education one
of the reasons why we have a crisis is
that we have a seeming inability to to
educate in districts that have large
numbers of of poor people in effect and
spending hasn't fixed this technology
hasn't fixed this you're doing some work
in working-class community bridgeport
connecticut
can you talk a bit about the signs of
kinds of things you're doing there and
is it relevant to some of these broader
social issues you have to take a step
back and recognize that what we're
trying to do in these environments the
challenges that we're trying to address
go way beyond technology and so the work
that we're doing in bridgeport is trying
to increase engagement try to provide
access to great quality content for
their educators provide professional
development services but
we have to start thinking about
community of learners and it's going to
take an entire community to help the
challenges of a bridgeport or
philadelphia new york city or in l.a you
go across this country and you visit a
lot of schools which we do all the time
and the gap is huge it's just huge and
we we have focused so much of our
attention on
on being critical of teachers and saying
that this is a bad teacher or this is a
bad school when many times the learning
environment is just so difficult that we
we visited a school in new york city the
avenue school which is one of the the
top schools and they have flat screen
tvs everywhere they have pipes coming
into the school that are bigger than
most corporations have they have you
know an i.t staff i think of 12 people
they have you know they have incredible
tools at their disposal even in the
lunchroom they have you know food
stations for different kinds of ethnic
you know foods and there's all kinds of
diversity it's an incredible learning
experience if you would go into that
school and you can't learn in that
environment you know you're just not
going to learn anywhere it's an amazing
environment now you go right down the
street and to a few other places in new
york city and you find a school where
you don't even really want to go into
the bathrooms they're just the learning
environment is dirty they don't have you
know nothing is new nothing is fresh and
everything is is crowded it's just it's
not a fun environment even the
playground area is an area that just
looks like it's concrete it's just not
an environment where you want to send
your child and so how those two children
are going to learn is going to be a
completely different experience but the
interesting thing
that has come out of all of our our
learnings around this is that even if
you went to the avenue school they would
tell you
that you're not going to get a better
educational experience there you're
going to get a better environmental
experience but you're not going to get
better instruction you're not
necessarily going to get better teachers
than what you have down the street but
what you are going to get is better
opportunity because it's an environment
that's safer in an environment that has
more content an environment that has
more tools and so the quality of the
teacher is so important
and back to your you know your question
earlier about how we develop you know
and are we selling technology and a lot
of digital content we can offer you an
all digital program we can offer you a
blended program we can offer you just a
print program
most schools will take blended but
they'll still use only print and they'll
do that because they simply don't have
the tools in place they want to try but
the tools aren't there so the problem
this country has is and and where
school boards etc get really concerned
and say we need more technology in the
classroom what they really need is more
infrastructure in the classroom because
the technology without the
infrastructures to support it is just a
device and so and the teacher in the
classroom without the professional
development know how to leverage that
device is just a teacher standing in
front of a classroom of kids using an
ipad and so it's a holistic approach
that we really have to think about it's
not just digital content it's not just a
device it's all of these things and an
environment that has the infrastructure
that can support it long term can you
adapt curriculum in a way that will be
engaging for students in that
environment or is the environment such a
distraction that there's not much you
can do about it we try you absolutely
let me be really clear you can
absolutely do it and i think that's why
we have the jobs that we have because we
believe that
it requires a lot of work it requires a
holistic approach it requires
recognition that technology in and of
itself is not going to be the answer but
there is no doubt in this country that
when you provide a great a great
educator with great resources with great
tools and a safe environment any kid can
be successful and we have to believe
that okay well i want to thank you for
coming here to be with us thank you this
is michael fitzgerald with mit slow
management review i want to thank you
for joining us for this discussion as
well on digital transformation and
education and we'll see you again soon
you